machen wir weiter mit ganz dramatischen
bildern von der a 1 dort fragte gestern
ein lkw ab das dramatische bei diesem
langen sattelzug handelt es sich um
deutschlands schönsten tag den großen
grauen wolf auf rädern so sah er mal aus
ja so sei er mal aus veredelt mit
einzigartiger lackierung preisgekrönt
als schönster lkw wir werden ihnen
gleich sehen aber am mittwoch geht er
eben in flammen auf und übrig ist nur
noch ein haufen schrott
so sah er mal aus veredelt mit
einzigartiger lackierung preisgekrönt
als schönster lkw
am mittwoch geht er in flammen auf übrig
ist nur ein haufen schrott
gegen 13 uhr fährt sebastian zielinsky
mit dem sattelzug über die a1 richtung
osnabrück plötzlich bemerkte er einen
reifenplatzer
nur wenige momente später steht der
sattelzug beladen mit lebensmitteln in
flammen als die feuerwehr eintrifft
brennt der lkw lichterloh
die gesamte autobahn muss für die
löscharbeiten gesperrt werden das
problem dass immer die wasserversorgung
teilweise im pendelverkehr
beziehungsweise dann rohrleitungen
verlegen schlauchleitung verlegen bis
zum abend dauert der einsatz schnell ist
jedoch klar von dem lastwagen ist nicht
viel zu retten besonders bitter der
truck hatte eine ganz besondere
einzigartige lackierung mit der gewann
er 2009 10 sogar den publikumspreis bei
einem wettbewerb um die schönsten lkw
die lackierung erzählte die geschichte
der schlacht im teutoburger wald zur
zeit der römer doch so schade die
zerstörung des lkw auch ist das bei dem
feuer niemand verletzt wird ist die
eigentliche gute nachricht
das stimmt natürlich und wir sprechen
jetzt mit dem lkw fahrer
höchstpersönlich sebastian zielinsky
head zielinsky wir haben gerade diese
schrecklichen bilder ihres ausgebrannten
lkw s gesehen was geht ihnen durch den
kopf wenn sie das jetzt noch mal revue
passieren lassen wie schmerzhaft ist das
so es ist es ist schmerzhaft
warum soll ich das warum soll ich das
verschweigen
vor allem da ich den lkw vor kurzem
übernommen habe war auch sehr stolz
drauf dass es schaffen so ein lkw
anvertraut und ja es ist nun mal
passiert kann ich nun mal nicht ändern
wie war das für sie wenn sie mit diesen
tollen wagen unterwegs waren auf den
straßen welche reaktionen haben tiger
bekommen
also ich habe durchgehend positive
reaktionen bekommen
es war für mich sehr ungewohnt weil
eigentlich bin ich nicht so ein typ der
gerne im mittelpunkt steht
hat mich auf jeden fall mit stolz
erfüllt diesen lkw zu fahren und gerade
auch für die firma was war denn der
auslöser des brandes können sie das
schon irgendwie
also der auslöser ist definitiven
reifenplatzer gewesen die nicht gemerkt
habe auf rechten seite habe dann den lkw
glücklicherweise sofort fangen können
und auf dem pannenstreifen überziehen
nur leider war der pannenstreifen zu
kurz wenn dann auf dem
beschleunigungsstreifen
gekommen von einer autobahnauffahrt wo
man dann erst zum stehen gekommen und
dann habe ich halt wie gesagt
spiegel rauch aufsteigen sehen wenn dann
aus schnell ausgestiegen weil hätte auch
staub oder direkt von der autobahn sein
und dann habe ich auch am reifen schon
die ersten flammen gesehen
also das sieht wir sehen die bilder hier
ja auch nach einem totalschaden aus
schauen wir nach vor werden sie einen
neuen bekommen wieder so einen schicken
lkw hinter ihnen steht ja schon einer
ja das ist
ich denke mal dass er wieder so einer
kommen wird die frage ist nur wann ja
also ich denke mal dass die firma mir
noch mal so einen lkw anvertraut also
davon gehe ich mal von aus java sandra
hat gerade gesagt hat wie was ist denn
das für den wagen wer da hinter ihnen
steht der macht ja auch einiges her
ja der macht einiges her wir haben auch
einige von solchen lkws
und der den fährt mein kollege also der
ist leider besetzt
dann wünschen wir ihnen viel glück dass
sie auch bald wieder
außergewöhnliches fahrzeug bekommen und
wir halten ausschau auf den deutschen
autobahnen und dann winken wir ihnen
einmal zu vielen dank